[Musique]
bonsoir avec six poulains merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france à hier
à vous le savez donc le président a fait
plusieurs annonces à on était ensemble
pour pour les commenter mais il y avait
aussi celles concernant la relance
économique et social à commencer par
cette réforme des retraites et
l'assurance chômage
on commence par la réforme des retraites
un c'est ce qui pique le plus d'ailleurs
fin des régimes spéciaux âge légal
repoussé mais neil mac row la remise sur
la table avec un bémol elle sera engagée
dès que les conditions sanitaires le
permettront en gros qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'il mêle macro
pays un agenda qui n'est pas celui ni
des échéances électorales qu'elles
soient municipales régionales ou autres
ni même ce qu'attend le peuple français
les partenaires sociaux il est là parce
que il a été élu sur une promesse de
réformes il était celui qui devait
réformer cette france sclérosé la faire
entrer dans la modernité et faire en
sorte que la france devienne un pays
comme un autre
que ce soit sur la réforme des retraites
la réforme de l'assurance chômage ou
autre l'idée est simple c'est que la
france ne doit plus être cette
république sociale qu'elle a été elle
coûte trop cher et puis finalement il
faut créer de nouveaux marchés de la
dette donc mails macro aujourd'hui son
rôle de président de la république cette
mise en scène qui l'a fait hier devant
la tour eiffel avec ses millions de
caméras
c'était assez particulier pour
l'allocution présidentielle eh bien il
est là pour dire peu importe il ya le
grand navire us il ya une crise mais je
dois m'en tenir à mon agenda à mon ordre
du jour est celui là est claire je dois
faire des réformes sans cela je ne
pourrais pas me représenter parce que je
ne retiens qu'une réforme est donc il va
pousser
évidemment pour que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage la récente des
retraites arrive à terme
alors même que les partenaires sociaux y
compris le medef et d'autres sont tout à
fait vent debout contre cette idée de
réforme qui n'arrive pas au bon moment
puisque entre temps est arrivée une
crise sanitaire qui complique tous les
plans évidemment débat le lagon alors il
n'y a pas que la réforme des retraites
il ya aussi la controversée réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui fait grincer
les dents qui a été abordé par le chef
de l'état il se justifie d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron le modèle social
français est un joyau qu'il faut
protéger pas sûr que les partenaires
sociaux l'entendre de la même oreille
mais pas du tout d'ailleurs c'est un
discours à tiroirs dire qu'il faut
protéger le modèle social français en le
détruisant c'est tout à fait pervers est
tout à fait d'ailleurs manipulateur je
ne veux pas de commander les formes
sociales français en faisant une bête
coville qui va coûter des milliards
d'euros à la france alors même que nous
ne savons pas comment nous allons
rembourser aujourd'hui nous avons avec
la banque centrale européenne
un euro qui nous permet évidemment
d'emprunter sur les marchés
internationaux et c'est formidable et
vaincrons a profité de ce plan de
relance en disant que les gaffes en
payeront les grandes entreprises
internationales pedro et puis on se rend
compte que washington n'est pas tout à
fait d'accord et qu'il va falloir faire
autre chose et que finalement cette taxe
qui devait financer cette dette covin ne
va peut-être pas arrivé au moment
opportun
alors cette dette qu'ovide c'est très
simple cet endettement de l'état un
point tel que nous allons et bien
étouffés par la dette c'est nous les
français les contribuables qui allons
devoir la payer d'une façon ou d'une
autre
de quoi qu'il en coûte il est le couac
il va vous en coûter nous en coûter que
ce soit l'assurance chômage ou les
retraites travailler plus plus longtemps
être moins indemnisé si jamais vous êtes
dans la difficulté de chercher un emploi
c'est ça le programme demel macron c'est
d'une violence sociale sans nom c'est la
solde pour tous compte de la république
sociale et c'est son programme et le dit
d'ailleurs ouvertement lors de son
allocution bière finalement en utilisant
la crainte du virus pour faire passer ce
programme qui est d'une violence inouïe
par rapport à ce que nous connaissons de
l'état social français pour dire que
tout ça doit changer et que dorénavant
c'est tous contre tous et chacun pour
soi c'est le programme des mâles macron
c'est ainsi qu'il l'a présenté en disant
que finalement c'est les non vaccinés
qui sont responsables de la non violence
de la perte de compétitivité de
l'économie française donc il trouvera
des boucs émissaires mais au final tous
les français vaccinés ou non devront
travailler plus longtemps auront moins
de retraite et vont voir la disparition
de la république sociale sous le régime
d belle macro alors il à préciser
ses ambitions emmanuel macron pour les
prochains mois on imagine avec en
perspective une campagne de réélection
il veut réindustrialiser la france -
dépendance de l'étranger
c'est un tournant c'est encore une fois
une manipulation assez grossière de la
part de ce président bacrot puisqu'ils
pensent que la france va devenir
indépendante en étant totalement
dépendante de vaccins allemands et
américains très bien après tout pourquoi
pas à la souveraineté finalement il ne
sait pas ce que ça veut dire mais là ça
devient vraiment critique parce que
qu'est-ce qu'il a déroulé hier dans son
discours il a parlé de ses secteurs qui
vont être les secteurs d'avenir
l'intelligence artificielle bien sûr les
nouvelles technologies tout ce qui est
dans ce fameux livre le grétry 7 du
forum de davos de klaus schwab de dire
que davantage le numérique va sauver
l'économie et c'est là que les nouveaux
emplois pour se créer mais il y as entre
la création des nouveaux emplois et la
destruction des emplois existants une
période très difficile où finalement les
gens qui vont perdre leur emploi ne vont
pas en retrouver ne pourront pas être
formé pour être les futurs travailleurs
de demain alors on voit bien que jean
michel blanc pierre s'active pour faire
en sorte que le pack ne veulent plus
rien dire que l'éducation nationale ne
soit plus là pour créer des citoyens
éclairés mais des travailleurs formaté
pour finalement que servir d'armé de
réserve à ce qui va être l'économie
numérique de demain
mais le discours des malades mâcon
d'hier qui moi m'a inquiété à guetter de
nombreux français est en train
simplement de mettre en place ce qui est
écrit dans ce grétry c'est de dire que
le numérique l'écologie verte doit
prendre le dessus et que les poches de
croissance seront dans ces nouveaux
emplois dans ces nouveaux secteurs
d'activité or aujourd'hui il faut les
filières il faut la capacité de le faire
et qui sont les champions du numérique
qui sont les champions également de
l'écologie ou du moins de l'énergie
verte et renouvelable
ce ne sont pas les français ce ne sont
même pas les européens se sont encore
une fois les gars femmes les grandes
entreprises américaines ou chinoises qui
vont encore gagner davantage d'argent
avec les politiques mises en place par
nos gouvernants notamment emmanuel
macron et ça me fait vraiment beaucoup
de
de pitié même d' inquiétude de voir
qu'un président français est capable de
parler de souveraineté sans mettre en
place aucune filière de souveraineté si
ce n'est celle de la finance de la start
up nation et à terre que aujourd'hui une
start up est d'abord un produit
financier avant de créer un produit ou d
emplois je ne vois pas en fait comment
cela peut fonctionner avec le poids de
la dette qu'ovide qui va nous être
imposée est la difficulté de la finance
et puisqu'aujourd'hui les gars femmes
évidemment ont les moyens d'empêcher
cette accession qui sont demandées par
les gouvernants européens sanitaire si
vous allez au restaurant très
prochainement la petite dédicace de
saison merci à vous